sixty percent of Europeans don't do any
kind of sport and probably about fifty
percent of them don't really do enough
physical activity to get any sort of
health benefit that's the motivation
world world health organization and
European Commission have kind of come
together to say physical inactivity is a
massive challenge the European
population it needs changing the earth
is a problem everywhere if you're not
active then for sure the future we will
have a huge and bigger problem at a
young age people aren't getting into the
behavior and attitude of participating
in regular sport what does that cost in
terms of bariatric care or secondary
conditions or mental health issues later
in life we have not a real culture or
playing sport just as a game like an
activity an ordinary activity for
everybody Sport is an important social
activity which helps people creating and
developing community skills and social
space science have proven how kids that
do sport develop themselves
psychological development the cognitive
capacity will be greater and in the kids
who who actually are not active in
sports how they develop and then the
youth difference la Patek sportiva 18
manière de gondia a decir que sunken
disco Phil educación surfer dispersion
seller Apollo satin amor de Regla
europea key parameter as agenda proved
walk on the other do venir de zama dc2
again we work with 11,000 kids and maybe
two to three hundred will go on to
competition level but for the other ten
thousand that we work with is this idea
that there's a group of them and there's
a team
clearly there's a benefit at an
individual level that if they're more
active they feel better but what does it
employer get from me they get workers
were happy people work who are healthy
people who come to work the absenteeism
rates go down and finally probably
having more productive employees this
September we will see the very first
European week of sport the week is for
everyone regardless of the age
background or fitness level one week
full week to create really a culture to
create a momentum we need to lead by
example parents school teachers whoever
is part of society should think about
how much they can influence the European
week of sport is actually really really
important to give people a starting
point a time at which they decide this
is what I'm going to start this behavior
but also it's making them feel less
isolated in this decision the hardest
thing to do with anything is to start
and once you started it doesn't take
long for a behavior become a habit the
European week of sport will be focused
around for particular key settings so we
have education schools universities and
colleges and that will springboard them
into a workplace when they take on an
employed life they can then decide which
particular things will they go on and
continue to do in the social sense some
people don't go to work so where else
can they go the settings clearly are
important local parks local natural
environments the green spaces that are
available for people and the final
opportunity is the more structured
physical activity we've got fitness
centers we've got clubs that will
provide particular kinds of sport
choices for people
toothless initiative keeper met ala
population data salsabila zhi de pavo
filippo a la casa sua da la mujer leash
allegory bien audio video a tu zookeeper
contributed lct leisure park aikido at
hogwash I think Nelson Mandela has given
the world a fantastic example how he has
your sport to united whole country if
the whole country can be united then we
definitely can get into the communities
and use sports as a tool to create
inclusive environment for everybody the
European week of sport is a genuine
European exam we would like to inspire
people to be active during the sports
week and beyond during the whole year we
had to be able really to continue
talking about European weaker sport feed
the next year and then we create a
culture